[Music]
a new virus emerges and spreads like
wildfire in order to contain it
researchers must first collect data
about who's being infected two main
viral testing techniques are critical
one tells you if you have the virus and
the other shows if you've already had it
so how exactly do these tests work PCR
or polymerase chain reaction testing
targets the virus's genetic material in
the body and is used to diagnose someone
who is currently infected yet this
genetic material may be present in such
imperceptible amounts that actually
detecting it is difficult this is where
PCR comes in it's widely used to amplify
genetic information to large enough
quantities that it can be readily
observed to develop a PCR test for a
never-before-seen virus researchers
first sequence its genetic material or
genome and identify regions that are
unique to that specific virus PCR then
targets these particular segments a PCR
test begins by collecting a sample this
can be blood for hepatitis viruses feces
for poliovirus
and samples from the nose or throat for
coronaviruses the sample is taken to a
central laboratory where PCR is
performed to test for the presence of
the virus's genome genetic information
can be encoded via DNA or RNA HPV for
example uses DNA while Tsarskoe v2 the
cause of covert 19 uses RNA
before running the PCR the viral RNA if
present must be reversed transcribed to
make a strand of complimentary DNA
researchers then run the PCR if the
virus is present in the sample its
unique regions of genetic code will be
identified by complementary primers and
copied by enzymes one strand of DNA
becomes hundreds of millions which are
detected using probes marked with
fluorescent dye if the PCR machine
senses fluorescence the sample has
tested positive for the virus
meaning the individual is infected
immunoassays on the other hand tap into
the immune systems memory of the virus
showing if someone has previously been
infected they work by targeting virus
specific antibodies generated by the
immune system during infection these are
specialized classes of proteins that
identify and fight foreign substances
like viruses immunoassays may detect IgG
antibodies the most abundant class and
IgM antibodies the type that's first
produced in response to a new infection
the presence of IgM antibodies suggests
a recent infection but since it can take
the body over a week to produce a
detectable amount they're unreliable in
diagnosing current infections meanwhile
IgG antibodies circulate for an extended
period after infection
the president's usually indicates that
someone was exposed and recovered before
the immunoassay health professionals
draw blood from an individual this
sample then comes into contact with a
portion of the virus of interest if the
body has in fact been exposed to the
virus in the past the body's virus
specific antibodies will bind to it
during the test this reaction produces a
change in color indicating with the
sample tested positive and of the
individual has been exposed to the virus
immunoassays are especially important
when it comes to retro actively
diagnosing people who were infected but
went untested and there's exciting
potential for those who have developed
immunity to a virus in some cases their
blood plasma could be used as treatment
in people who were currently fighting it
PCR and immunoassays are always in the
process of becoming more accurate and
efficient for example innovations in PCR
have led to the use of self-contained
testing devices the relay results within
one our digital PCR which quantifies
individual pieces of target DNA shows
promise in further boosting accuracy and
although amino acids are difficult to
develop quickly researchers in Singapore
were able to create one for Tsarskoe v2
even before covert 19 was declared a
pandemic these tests along with the
scientists who developed them and the
health professionals who administer them
are absolutely essential and when
deployed early they can save millions of
lives
we know that our bodies produce virus
specific antibodies but how learn more
about your body's defenses with this
video or find out how a very different
medical test works with this one
[Music]